He dibujado algunas curvas por aquí, y observa
que estas curvas a la izquierda pertenecen a una
familia que llamamos polígonos, mientras que las
curvas que están a la derecha no pertenecen a esa
familia. Ahora, ¿por qué algunas curvas pertenecen
a esta familia y otras no? Bueno, para pertenecer
a esta familia debes cumplir algunas reglas. Lo
que quiero que hagas es que veas a los miembros
de esta familia y los compares con los que
no son miembros de esa familia. Observando
estos dos grupos, ¿puedes establecer cuáles son
estas reglas? Bueno, si piensas un poco en esto,
te darás cuenta de que una de las reglas puede ser
que todas estas curvas se componen de segmentos de
líneas rectas, no hay curvas dobladas como esta,
entonces, tal vez sea la primera regla: que se
componen sólo de segmentos de recta, se componen
sólo de segmentos de recta. Perfecto. Pero,
¿es la única regla? Si esa fuera la única regla,
entonces, observa: esta sería parte de la familia
de polígonos porque sólo está hecho de segmentos
de recta, y entonces esta también debería de ser
parte de la familia de polígonos porque está
hecha sólo de segmentos de recta al igual que
este. Entonces, tal vez existan más reglas para
pertenecer a esta familia, tal vez esta sea una
regla pero sigamos buscando. Entonces, ¿qué otra
regla es posible? Esta figura no es parte de la
familia, pero esta sí lo es, y hay una diferencia
muy pequeña entre estas dos: que esta es abierta
y esta es cerrada, entonces podemos darnos cuenta
de que todas estas son cerradas, lo que significa
que tienen un interior y un exterior que
llamaremos la región interior y la región
exterior. Así que podemos pensar que otra regla
que deben de seguir los miembros de esta familia
es que deben de ser cerrados, así que, si eres
una curva, debes ser cerrada y estar compuesta
de segmentos de recta para poder pertenecer a esta
familia llamada polígonos. Porque observa, si sólo
pedimos que sean cerradas, entonces el círculo
formaría parte de esta familia, pero no lo es;
si sólo pedimos que sean cerradas, esta curva
y esta otra curva también serían un polígono,
pero sabemos que no son parte de esta familia.
Entonces tenemos estas dos reglas, es decir:
que las curvas sean cerradas y que se compongan
sólo de segmentos de recta. Pero, ¿es todo lo
que necesitamos para pertenecer a esta familia de
polígonos? Observa esto: esta curva que tenemos
aquí es cerrada y sólo está hecha de segmentos
de recta, y esta otra también, entonces debemos
preguntarnos: ¿es esto suficiente para pertenecer
a esta familia?, ¿son las únicas dos reglas que
necesitamos? Si ahora vemos esta figura, puedes
ver que está hecha sólo de segmentos de recta y es
cerrada, tiene una región interna y una externa.
Pensemos en esta otra, esta figura de cierta
forma es cerrada y está compuesta de segmentos de
recta, entonces ¿qué sucede?, ¿necesitaremos una
pequeña regla adicional para nuestras curvas?
Sí, necesitamos que las curvas sean del tipo
que denominamos simples. Si recordamos, en una
curva simple, si tomamos una esquina como ésta,
sólo debemos tener dos líneas que salgan de
ella. En este caso tenemos tres; por acá podemos
observar que tenemos tres líneas saliendo de
este punto, por lo tanto, no son curvas simples;
mientras que si observamos por aquí, de todas
las esquinas sólo salen dos líneas como máximo,
y de hecho siempre tienen dos líneas porque deben
de ser cerradas. Si observas todas estas curvas,
todas tienen sólo dos líneas que salen de las
esquinas, en otras palabras: nunca tendrás dos
regiones internas -como aquí- ya que sólo debemos
tener una región interna. Ahora sabemos que
siempre y cuando una curva siga todas estas tres
reglas será miembro de esta familia que llamamos
polígonos, deben de ser curvas simples, cerradas
y deben componerse sólo de segmentos de recta.